in what internet commenters are calling
an about frigging time moment square
enix is rethinking its bid to appeal to
a mass audience after the success of the
distinctly Japanese bravely default I'm
mark Walton and this is a game spot news
update Square Enix had lost its focus
after trying to make games that appeal
to a wide global audience Square Enix
president you're Sookie Matsuda told the
Nick and trendy in an interview not only
did they end up being games that weren't
for the Japanese but they ended up being
incomplete titles that won't even fit
for a global audience on the other hand
there are games like the JRPG we made
for the Japanese audience with the
proper elements bravely default which
ended up selling well all around the
world Matsuda mentioned hitman
absolution as an example of the game
that had a hard time in attempting to
appeal to this mythological global
audience and suffered as a result the
development team for hitman absolution
really struggled in this regard they
implemented a vast amount of elements
for the mat instead of for the core fans
as a way of trying to get as many new
players as possible so as for the Triple
A titles we're currently developing for
the series we basically want to go back
to their roots and focus on the core
audience while working hard on content
that can have fans say things like this
is the Hitman we know I believe that
this is the best way for our development
studios to display their strengths
Square Enix has suffered over the last
year and has restructured many of its
operations following an extraordinary
loss at the start of 2013 the company
now expects to return to full profit
this year fueled partly by the
successful relaunch of final fantasy 14
a realm reborn Square Enix is now
refocusing is efforts on returning its
triple-a series to their roots and
appealing to core fans are sweet justice
at last but what do you guys think are
you happy that Square Enix is returning
to its roots or you all like hey where's
my god damn mass appeal people let us
know in the comments below and I'll see
you next time
you